because Loki obviously changes how we
look at the timeline in plenty of ways
now throughout the series dozens of
dates are listed on various screens but
I'm only going to mention the historical
settings that we actually visit and
we'll start with the big bang which
based on the opening six opening imagery
and the way this series sees time as
cyclical may also be the universal big
crunch the n79 A.D that was the
destruction of Pompeii briefly
interfered with by Loki this would have
caused the Nexus event but the
apocalyptic nature of Mount vesuvius's
explosion cleared it but then we're
gonna get to pre-965 A.D but alternate
this is when young Sylvia was arrested
by the TV from Asgard and she told Loki
in episode 6 that she was pruned before
he was born which was in the year 965
but that line didn't make a lot of sense
to a lot of US unless you consider
templication number 21 the timeline is
actually composed of infinite Universal
strands or Loops this is what Mike
Waldron was trying to explain in the
interview time as we know it is actually
history coiling back on itself again and
again
[Music]